Miroslav - thanks for receiving us here at
the Yale Divinity School at Yale University,
New Haven.
You are professor here for Faith and Culture.
To introduce you to the audience of the Nexus
Institute: where do you come from, and why
have you chosen to become a theologian?
I was born in what was then Yugoslavia, and
I was born to a man who was a minister.
Most of our life revolved around faith and
the life of a small community, and I promptly
rebelled when I was about 13 years of age.
Then I discovered faith when I was 16, and
from then on I couldn't quite help myself
but think through the basic issues of faith,
which are the basic issues of human existence.
And, by the way, at that time in Yugoslavia,
being a theologian was really cool.
It was something that had to do not just with
my existence, but also with opposition to
the reigning regime.
We thought we were doing something counter-cultural,
something on which the future, not only of
our lives, but of our country and the world
depended.
We live in a time in which a vast majority
of people will realize that, to save the world,
we have science and technology, and politics
can play a role, international law will play
a role.
But what is it that theology has to offer
to the world?
Well, theology is about, in many ways, reflection
on the nature of human existence, the problem
of human existence.
And theology can attend to global issues of
justice, but what theology also does is that
it zeroes in on the deep recesses of the human
heart and human desire.
It tries to examine who we as human beings
are as connected to what is it that we identify
with, project ourselves into; how the dynamics
of our desire functions.
I think that we can't save the world unless
we save the desire of each human being.
Theology has very much to say about this.
But what's the difference between philosophy,
psychology, social sciences and theology?
Theology, at least Christian theology, thematizes
the world and human beings, not just in themselves.
It thematizes them as themselves only as they
are related to something that's beyond the
boundary of this world, that's beyond the
boundary of their existence.
In other words, it thematizes human beings
as fundamentally related to transcendence, so that
the world is not just cosmos, the world is
creation.
The world is a gift, and therefore always
more than what appears to our senses.
In the world it is always the case that more
than the world is the case, to quote Sloterdijk's
comment about secularism.
This is what theology brings to our attention.
In our own lives, we are always more than
just ourselves, we live excentric existences.
And this reference of the entire world and
human beings to transcendence is fundamental
to us.
I think that if we do not think of human beings
in those terms, we cannot understand who human
beings are, we cannot understand what the
problem of human existence is, and we certainly
cannot imagine what salvation might look like.